[Müzik]
Herkese merhaba sizlere ilham vermek
için gelmedim Daha çok ilhamın nerede
olduğunu göstermek için geldim
32 yıllık edebiyat öğretmeniyim 20
yıldır doğa fotoğrafları çekiyorum
bir öğretmen hayal edin
sabah güneş doğmadan uyanıyor
takım elbiselerini giyiyor
okula gidecek zannediyorsunuz değil mi
Tabii ki okula gidiyor Fakat erken
gidiyor Neden Çünkü güneş doğmadan o
alana gitmek zorunda hangi alana Hani
insanlardan kaçarcasına
gizlenmiş o küçük canlıları o güzel
canları keşfetmeye gidiyor
Kapıdan çıkarken kitap çantası soruyor
boynunu da fotoğraf makinesi asıyor ve
yola koyuluyor
Güneş Doğarken onları geceledikleri
yerlerde buluyor Ve fotoğraflamaya
başlıyor elini çabuk tutmak zorunda
çünkü Güneş doğduktan sonra biraz
ilerledikten sonra güneşten aldıkları
enerji kaçacaklar poz vermeyecekler
mümkün olduğu kadar sabah erken vaktinde
onların uyuşkanlarını yakalamam lazım ki
bana güzel modellik yapsınlar
sabah o yüzden benim için çok önemli hep
o yüzden okula 2 saat önceden giderim
fotoğraf çeke çeke giderim takım
elbiseli bir adam görürseniz yolda
Elinde fotoğraf makinesi varsa yerlerde
yuvarlanıyorsa bir iki o akıl hocadır
Bu yüzden zaman zaman çok eleştiriler
alırım ya Koskoca öğretmensin hiç sana
yakışıyor mu yerlerde yuvarlanmak börtü
böcekle uğraşmak böyle garip garip
zamanında eleştirilerde alıyorsunuz
Tabii sevdiğiniz işi tutkuyla yaparsanız
hiçbir şeyi umursamıyorsunuz Hatta
Yağmurlu havalarda bile bu Doğa Peki
küçük canlıları çekmeye çalışıyorsunuz
şimdi
bu kadar güzel fotoğraf çektiğimi
fark eder öğrencilerim velilerim çevrem
dediler ki hocam neden dua yarışmalarına
katılmıyorsunuz Tamam katılayım dedim
uluslararası yarışmalara katıldım Asya
ve Avrupa'da yapılan bütün yarışmaları
katıldım 40 farklı ülkeden
5000 Ödül ve sergileme aldım
[Alkış]
Fiat uluslararası fotoğraf Federasyonu
efliyaf bronzala layık gördü beni yani
mükemmel fotoğrafçı ünvan umaraya
geliyor
Fujifilm firmasının Japon mühendisleri
bir objektif üretmişler Ya bunu kime
gönderelim ya Türkiye'de Akın hoca
varmış onu gönderelim çalışıyor mu
çalışmıyor mu bakalım demişler
göndermişler
3 ay önce test ettim
ve
objektörle çekmiş olduğum fotoğrafları
fuşya
tekrar bir değişiklik yapıp dünya
piyasasına benim fotoğraflarımla Ayrıca
bir objektifin seri numarasında
akınacağı yazarak bana hediye ettiler
[Alkış]
bundan sonra birçok projeler hazırladım
kanarya adalarına Tutun da az olurları
kadar fotoğraf sergileri açtım Sağ
olsunlar değer verdiler inanın Doğa
kadar önemli bir şey yok Eğer Dua yoksa
bizde maalesef yokuz projemin adı Göz
Göze neden eskiler ne diyor İnsanlar
kendi aralarında lisan-ı hâl ile ve
lisanı kal ile anlaşırlar lisan-ı hal
konuşma demektir lisan-ı hal Durum
vaziyet demektir biz bazen dertlerimizi
konuşarak anlatmayız bakarız
sıkıntılı görünüyorsun deriz Mutsuzsun
deriz dostlara bizim için önemlidir
hangi Dostlar önemlidir
söylemeden derdimi bilen Dostlar
önemlidir
O nedenle dedim ki; bu kadar güzel
canlıları insanlarla göz göze getirmem
lazım
göz göze gelirlerse
anlaşabiliriz
onların dertlerini sıkıntılarını
öğrenebiliriz
Ben de kalktım o
Makro objektifle onların portreleri
çektim
dikkat edin normal günlük hayatta
gördüklerinizden daha farklı insanlarla
onları göz göze getirmeye çalıştım
şimdi
bir verdiğimiz tiksindiğimiz
gördüğümüz zaman hemen öldürmeye
çalıştığımız canlılarla karşı karşıya
geldiğimizde göz göze geldiğimizde
Burak sayacağınızı düşünüyorum Çünkü
artık onların gözlerini görüyorsunuz
Yalnız ben şöyle bir sıkıntım var
Evet ama güzel tarafı var kıpkırmızı
gözü var değil mi
uzun süre objektifimle onlarla göz göze
gelirken
bakışıyoruz ya
bakışarak anlaşıyoruz ya
böcekleri aşık olmaya başladım göz göze
geldiğim için yani o müthiş bir şey
sanki bir şeyler anlatmaya çalışıyorlar
şöyle diyorlar
teşekkür ederiz
Biz olmazsak Siz olmazsınız sanırım biz
anlıyorsunuz değil mi gerçekten böcekler
yoksa dünya yoktur böcekler yoksa yaşam
yoktur Biraz sonra örnekle göstereceğim
hepsini
buluşlar ve medeniyetler nasıl ortaya
çıkıyor
bizim zekamızla mı bunun üzerine biraz
düşünelim
hop Rose vardı hatırlarsanız Amerika adı
gazeteci ressam çok güzel tablolar
çizerdi
hayranlıkla izlerdik küçükken televizyon
kanalında
Şuraya bir daha koyalım Şuraya bir göl
Nehir bir gökyüzü olsun
Şuraya da bir ağaç koyalım bu ağaç
üzerinde ışık olsun mutlu ve neşeli
olsun ne kadar keyifli anlatırdı
fakat şunu dikkat ettim bütün
tablolarında hep aynı şey ama içinde bir
şey eksik
insan yok fark ettiniz mi Neden bopros
oraya insan figürü koymuyor acaba
ağaçlar neşesinden bir şey kaybeder diye
mi korkuyordu
bir hafta insan oraya çıktığı andan
itibaren
doğanın zarar geleceğinden
küçükleniyordu değil mi
Biz de öyle yapalım hadi Hemen
başlayalım
dağa koyalım orman koyalım oralar
tepeler koyalım Göller koyalım Hadi bir
de İnsan ilk insan olsun
çok zeki yaratılmış
düşünüyor Ah ne kadar çok işim var
tekerleği icat edeceğim arabalar icat
edeceğim binalar dikeceğim çok çok kişi
var ama çok zeki olmasına rağmen hiçbir
şey yapamıyor Neden Çünkü ilham
kaynakları eksik ilham kaynağı ne
böcekler Çünkü o ortamda bakıyor ki bir
şeyler hareket ediyor ama bunlar burada
yaşıyorsa ben de yaşayabilirim bakıyor
orada bir tanesi ne yapıyor
köprü yapıyor
ve örümcekten
köprü yapmasını öğreniyor tekerlek
keşfettiğini düşünüyorsunuz ama
bakıyorsunuz orada bir tane böcek var
bir şeyler yuvarlıyor dışkı böceği
tekerleği
keşfetmiş oluyor Yine aynı şekilde
çokgen altıgen gibi geometrik şekiller
keşfediyor kimler sayesinde
Arılar sayesinde
yine aynı şekilde teleskop teknolojisi
geliştiriyorlar arıların altıgen
gözünden istifade ederek
yine aynı şekilde
enjektöre iğne keşfediyorlar
siirtler sayesinde
yine ağır şekilde adli tıpta bir ceset
ne zaman ölmüş hangi vakit ölmüş yine o
canlılar sayesinde tespit ediyorlar
yine aynı şekilde
yusufçuklar sayesinde helikopterleri
düzenliyorlar yine aynı şekilde
uçakların kanatlarındaki dengeyi
sağlamak için yine suçlularda
yararlanıyorlar yine aynı şekilde birçok
binaların çatılarını yapmak için
yine o çok ince bütün fırtınalara
dayanıklı olan yusufçuğun kanalından
yararlanıyorlar
Evet uydu panelleri açılıp kapanan uydu
panelleri bugün Japonlar uğur
böceklerinin bu kanat yapıların
altındaki aşırı kapanan panellerine
bakarak uydu panelleri yapmaya
çalışıyorlar
yine aynı şekilde robot teknolojisinde
biliyorsunuz Örümceklerin reklam
bacaklarının özellikleri kullanıyor yine
aynı şekilde robot kol çalışan robotlar
Bunlar yine aynı şekilde peygamber
devesi veya Mart dediğimiz canlı
canlı gibi görünen o kollar mekanik
kollar bu peygamberlerle yapılıyor yine
çok önemli nokta dünyanın
ağaç protein ihtiyaç var içinden
biliyorsunuz bugün Avrupa'da Asya'da
birçok ülkelerde artık böcek
çiftleri var satış yapılıyor
girişimcilik yapmak
sizin Düşüncenizi bilmiyorum Yine aynı
şekilde bir böcek Borsası var
Avrupa'da böcekler yarıştırılıyor kavga
ediliyor
medeniyetler diyoruz ya medeniyette
böcekleri birini anlatıyorsa İşte bunlar
yine aynı şekilde
biyolojik savaşlar ki beni en çok
ülkeden taraf burası
zaman zaman duymuşsunuzdur gümrük
kapılarında kaçırılan böceklerin
yakalanışını Acaba neden o böcekler
kaçırılıyor genleri oynatıp tekrar
yaşadığı bölgeye iade edilip Acaba bir
şeyler mi yapmaya çalışılıyor Komplo
Teorisi diye düşünebilirsiniz
Evet tarımda çok önemli yerleri var
biliyorsunuz eğer Bunlar olmazsa bu
küçük canlılar olmasa domateslerimizi
portakallarımızı kiralarımızı Yiyemeyiz
bu gerçek Çünkü tozlaşma var döllenme
var bunların hepsini çocukluk
yıllarımızda
biyolojik kitaplarında okuduk
Evet tarımın en önemli işçilerinden bir
tanesi matislerdir halk arasında bunlara
peygamber devesinin sebebi de ön
ayaklarıyla dua eder gibi durduğu
içindir
kolları çok güçlüdür
çok meraklı hayvanlardır Uçan kaçan her
şeyi yakalarlar yakından baktığınız
zaman bir uzaylıya benzerler zannersiz
gibi Hollywood uzay filminde çıtırlamış
Aslında bakarsanız Demek ki sinema
sektöründe animasyoncular ne yapıyorlar
bunları örnek alıp Belki de figür olarak
oyuncu figür olarak yapıyorlar diye
düşünebilirsiniz şu anda görmüş
olduğunuz bu peygamber
develeri
dikkatli baktığımızda bazı peygamber
develerinin Mısır piramitlerindeki
resimlere benzediğini görürsünüz sanki
biraz Mısır firavunuyor veya Mısır
firavunların giymiş olduğu elbiseleri
andırıyor diye görüyorsunuz bakın bak
karşılaştığınızda Sanki benzerlik var
peki ne olabilir diye bir bakayım dedim
Nil Nehir kenarlarında buğdayların
[Müzik]
kollarını ellerini yalayarak temizlerler
Kelebekler biliyorsunuz bunlarda
duamızın konfetileri şairlere şiirlere
konu olmuş Romanlara konu olmuş cam
türlerimizdir ayaklarıyla tat alırlar
işleri güçleri çiçeklerin özlerine
tokmaktır ben mümkün olduğu kadar
bunlara bunları fotoğraflarken rahatsız
etmeden Sen demiştim ya sabah erkenden
gidiyorum Çünkü dertleri beslenmek
olduğu için onda rahatlıkla
fotoğraflayabiliyorum
renklerine baktığınız zaman ressamların
Tekstil sanayinin
örnek alabileceği güzellikten bir
yapıları var görmüş olduğunuz ekranda
gördüğünüz kanatlarına bakarsanız uyum
renk uyumlu Müthiş bu renk uyumu
sayesinde
insanlara birçok konularda ilham
verdikleri düşünüyorum
uğur böcekleri
bereketin sembolüdür çiftçilerin en
yakın dostlarıdır yıllarca kıtlık çeken
bir köye yaprak bitleri dadanmış
kurtulamıyorlar sonra kırmızı Bir bulut
geliyor işte O Bulut kırmızı Bulut uğur
böcekleri o yaprak bileklerini
temizliyor ve halk kıtlıktan kurtuluyor
O yüzden Uğur böcekleri ne diyorlar Yani
bu böceklere uğur böcekleri deniyorlar
değil mi çocukluğumuzda sık sık ne derdi
bir bizim çocukluğumuzda böcekler
kıymetliydi Uç Uç böceğim yarın düğün
olacak Annem sana terlik olmuş olacak
deyip uçmasını beklerdik uçarsın
Yusuf kadar güzel oldukları için bunları
yusufçuk adı verildiği söyleniyor Biraz
önce söylemiştim teknoloji ilham kaynağı
olan en güzel canlılardan bir tanesi
bunlarda Zararlı olan tarıma zarar olan
böcekleri yiyen canlılar kendi arasında
kız böceği
bir farklı alt kolları ayrılabiliyor
görmüş olduğunuz bir kız böceği görseli
Evet en güzeli de çiftleşme anları
çiftleşirken kalp yapan tek böcek
bu yusufçuklardır kız böcekleridir
Arılar tarbın vazgeçilmez
böcekleri
Einstein Eğer dünyadaki bütün Arılar
ölürse insanlığın ömrü
4 yıl sonra biter Karıncalar bunlarda
çalışkanlığını temsili tünellere sürekli
tohumları götürürler o tohumlar bir
zaman sonra yaşarır doğaya tabiata
katkıda bulunurlar bunların da böyle
faydası var örümcekler tiksiniyoruz
korkuyoruz ama bunların da
çok önemli insanlar faydası var o da şu
an çok Taşıyan kan emici canlıları
ağrıların düşünerek bizleri kurtarmış
oluyorlar özellikle sivrisinek gibi
türlere özel kenarlarında bazıları
ağlıyor bazıları zıplayarak yakalıyor
yine aynı şekilde Bunlar bazıları da
yengeç örümcekleri diyoruz beyaz
olanlarını Bunlar etkilerin rengine göre
değişim gösterebiliyorlar
Kısacası söylemek istediğim şey ekranda
görüyorsunuz doğanın sürekliliği ve
insan Yaşamının kalitesi küçük canlılara
bağlıdır teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]
[Müzik]